字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
觀眾朋友注意喔
最近詐騙盛行
請務必認明
郭子龍分析師的官方帳號
Facebook臉書只要看到贊助標示貼文
請立刻提高警覺
因為這百分之百是臉書詐騙
加入LINE後
先確認是否有銀色盾牌標章
還要點選大頭貼
只有粉絲人數超過18萬
才是真正的郭子龍分析師LINE的官方帳號
大家好 歡迎收看榮耀華爾街
今天是4月9號
我是主持人Lily
投資長好
大家好
今天台灣股市看起來很刺激
最後收紅
好奇怪
亞洲股市都弱勢
台灣股市怎麼收紅
其實最主要原因
台灣股市最近真的很強
第二個
跟什麼
台灣股市都只跟最強的
韓國股市強的時候
台灣股市跟著韓國股市走
那現在是廢半指數強
廢半股指數先創新高
台灣股市跟著它強
今天也漲了
今天看起來大部分都在平盤之下
可是臺灣股市拉上去了
可是很奇怪
臺灣股市拉上去了
上跪指數好像也是紅的
可是今天我剛才如果沒看錯的話
上漲加速跟下跌加速來看的話
我們剛看一下
因為剛收完盤
我記得沒有錯的話是
下跌加速
遠大於上漲的加速
尤其記憶體
不對啊
不應該這樣子你知道嗎
不應該這樣子
我沒有錯
下跌加速就已經超過1000加了
1800加裡面有1000多加
是下跌的
所以今天大家很不開心啊
很多人不開心
搞不清楚這行情
感覺好像只有全值可以買
沒有錯
一些股票有可能是我下個禮拜要買的標的
來2382的一個管達有沒有
今天這拉起來讓你看起來好像K線很強
他可能是噴出第一根而已
我就說過管達是基歐股
管達是TPU晶片
還有什麼
還有就是Google晶片跟
灰達晶片都有搶到訂單的
AI伺服器組專長的
所以都是一個好的公司
管達偉創鴻海 我說管達今年
我那時候記得沒錯
我說管達今年EPS30元以上
我應該去年是這樣講的
30元以上是滿有機會的
你看10倍本益比不到
前陣子10倍本益比不到
真的很可惜好不好
這是低膽股票
第二個這股票慢慢跟大家講
因為下禮拜準備要買
因為我覺得要稍花一點點在
二屋戰爭
不是二屋戰爭
美伊戰爭啊
為什麼
因為今天就有人說
哇美伊戰爭
你看你是不是符合我講的
所以我昨天講過一件事喔
我說就這行情
我不會說我100%對
甚至你可以說我錯
因為我沒有買在最低點
沒有關係因為我對自己也很苛
可是我說我邏輯沒有錯
我從頭到尾就告訴你這戰爭還有得打
那河母之海峽現在被封鎖了啊
那好玩是被封鎖他們兩個要談判了
那談判怎麼辦
會不會一談又破局了
蠻特別的會不會以色列又開始打起來了
可是現在最想要促成這個結局是誰
川普 所以這次有可能促成
可是川普又要很多
那一隻是依然也要很多
依然就故意用鴻浦之海夾掐住你
可是依然的東西都是不合道理的
都是不合道理 我們來看一下
我告訴大家 我說我邏輯沒有錯什麼意思
戰爭可能還會打
油價可能還會增加上去
然後呢
可是股市可能不会跌
因为股市已经动化了
不理他了
这就是股市好玩的地方
我还跟他讲说
说幸好我这股市经验多了
什么多
我说过我说好像2015年吧
这是英国脱欧
我猜对了
当店也大跌了
结果跌完以后每天都喷出去
所以这个就是股市好玩的地方
来
我们来看一下
你看
美一才说好停火
以軍以色列的軍隊轉頭血洗黎巴仁
伊朗木峰和母之海峽
所以今天我們的00642怎麼樣
還漲
還賺錢
今天一度漲了快4%
一度漲快4%
今天收盤價漲3%
3.35%
我們的
UOETF昨天大跌的時候還在賺錢
所以今天漲上去的時候
也算賺錢喔
還是賺錢喔
你去想看你要找他分析師好不好
那我們想一下喔
如果這原油ETF還漲
就是符合我說的嘛
戰爭他可能打下去
可是不影響股市
你看今天股市還繼續拉起來
所以我戰爭時間我稍微減短
除非是說整個大破局
然後兩方美軍正式要
怎麼樣
正式要入侵伊朗
我覺得川普沒這個膽量啊
很量 川普膽子很小
美伊才說好要停火
以軍轉頭學習黎巴勒
依然怒風荷姆之海峽
我說這個慘重點是
有沒有影響荷姆之海峽
那現在你看封鎖荷姆之海峽
股市還不理他
因為股市認為
他們都說說而已
以色列抱怨
不是以色列 依然抱怨
說你們說話不算話
結果嘴巴說不要
今天還是怎麼樣
要去巴基斯坦 怎麼樣
晚上要去巴基斯坦開會啦
周末的開會今天晚上就要去了
唉
所以我們來看一下
我昨天剛剛講
你看
轉頭學習黎巴嫩 依然怒風和母子海峽
我不知道這10項啊
怎麼辦啊
10點建議書怎麼辦啊
我昨天剛剛講喔
全面停火
含以色列跟真主黨
我不可能啊
昨天以色列還在打黎巴嫩耶
你別相信我講這句話
所以我昨天在預測的你已經告訴你的
今天雲油還會漲
因為戰爭還打下去嘛
這10點實在太苛刻了
伊朗這10點
美國怎麼會答應
你不安心
我們來看一下
來看一下重播看一下VCR來
跟我一下
看了以後就知道
來
這邊
4月8有沒有看到
4月8昨天
解除就解除
支付赔偿金
美军撤离中东就不可能了
支付赔偿金也不可能
现在有可能是说
哇 我让河姆之海峡
再支付我赔偿金
这可能可以接受
全面停我也没有
以色列像跟尼巴勒的政府团
还在打
就一向这样就不可能了
美军有可能撤离中东吗
你看我刚才说关这些就不可能了
是不是
結果昨天才新文出來你看我預告在前面
新文出來是甚麼
不好意思
這預測能力很強好不好
已經轉頭學習黎巴勒 依然怒風和睦之在下
沒有錯 可是我不要變政治專家
我也不要變分世技術做空喔 做太久喔會心裡不正常我沒有 我沒有 股票沒做空我頂多棋子就做空所以我不是罵一些做空老師不是不是不是 我沒有罵人
我不會去罵人
我哲哲到這年紀 我覺得還好
好像很多人說哲哲你這邊還好嗎
就動個小手術
這樣已經沒事了
可是說就是會比較喘一點點
會比較喘一點點
所以這個沒辦法用直播方式
可是我復原的力已經很厲害了
我復原的力已經很厲害了
所以哲哲也是愛大家啦
不然其實應該要多休息一下下
但是狀況很好
就是不要講話
可是我的工作就是要講話
就這麼簡單
所以我等要分段錄影
因為分段錄影
然後要趕著2點半播
2點半播
2點半播2點35播
所以我1點半就要錄完了
分段錄影
是跟大家講
下禮拜一應該就有機會直播了
好不好下禮拜一我愛你們啦
哲哲現在工作已經不是為了錢
是為了大家
這件事我看空也是為了讓你賺更多
那有沒有讓你賺到
我跟你講至少記憶體我沒讓你受傷害啊
一堆人嗆往記憶體
賞戶最喜歡的買記憶體啊
你覺得藍牙科現在這個是對嗎
欸這不對
這個我覺得記憶體有點變態
我是跟你講
今天走勢毛毛的你知道嗎
這個走勢今天有點毛毛的
藍牙科這樣走勢
代表大戶主力走掉了
來給我看啊
來給你看一下
這隻記憶體不應該這樣走
我給他看一下走勢的
你看那個Sandisk美光啊
然後三星啊
你們看一下
大家看一下
三星
你看三星對不對
轉上去對不對
至少人家還在高檔整理
W底嘛
人家是W底啊
或三個W
三個底啊
就是這三星走勢怎麼看到
好
SK海利4
至少都在打底啊
就是
打底啊對不對
這邊
跳空昨天跳空大漲
那我們來看一下 Sandisk
Sandisk看起來是要創新高耶
1000耶同學
要1000耶800多耶
那我們看一下他什麼
MU是美光
美光看起來也是要準備在挑戰前高
美光也是啊
這美光的走勢
這Sandisk的走勢喔
有沒有看到
這個是三星的走勢啊
這是這樣
海力士的走勢啊
是不是都
是不是
那個想問一下Lily
你有沒有覺得
感覺韓國的跟美國的
記憶體都比台灣強大很多
嗯沒錯
你覺得感覺差很多對不對
好像是耶
真的是差很多好不好
來來來
對那也是因為這樣
我最近比較給他少時間一點點
因為他 我覺得我跟大家沒什麼好瞞的
就是我跟他說
所以最近比較善氣不接下氣
可是我呼緣力算很強
所以我說1 不是1
不然你當作1
你再當2號好了 沒有啦
2號沒有啦開玩笑
我說那個莉莉會比較容易緊張
我說我現在沒辦法把你接話
所以他前面話先不用講
因為這樣子我這樣會比較差氣
會比較沒力
其實算厲害了啦
其實算厲害了
講話聲音越來越大聲
已經變好非常多了
对吧
我第一天上班的时候
我讲我讲
大家好
真的真的
复原力真的很强
真的很强
那时候莉莉还问我怎么录影
我说燃烧生命录影
第一天真的燃烧生命
投资长真的是爱大家
真的
真的如果你知道我私底下
跟私底下的气力
跟现在
第一天私底下的气力
跟那时候录影的气力
就知道我真的是
牺牲生命照料大家
再跟大家讲
其实只要多休息就好了
小事啊
可是复原力现在越来越好了
好来
那我们来看一下哦
所以先跟大家讲
因为有些人担心我
不用担心
我也不想让他多讲
就觉得好像奇怪是不是
做错了
一只只要逃避什么
怎么现在
不给他直播而已
不是啦
没有必要啦
我现在对不喜欢的人
我就直接封锁
懒得跟他们讲那么多了
所以你们不要在我这边抱怨
不喜欢就可以离开了
因为抱怨没有意义
你抱怨不会让你多赚钱
是不是
这一波空手
你要跟我做什么
你说你会赚
你真的相信很多人说
賺那麼多嗎
大部分閃門都是買記憶體吧
大部分分析師
比較投顧老師都是買記憶體哦
我跟你講
所以我沒有投顧老師
我可以做品質保證
其他要投顧我沒有辦法
你看記憶體現在很長
這記憶體2408
來看一下
那你看670
密集電
密集電這看起來像破
他走勢跟人家這個
人家記憶體跟別人
跟我們記憶體不一樣
人家記憶體躺到這邊來這邊殺下去
這不對啊
對有點誇張
然後3260微干
所以也是怪怪的
所以這一波你看反南波
很多老師這一波業績那時候很好
因為這邊買了記憶體賺了你看
一下從250到500賺一倍
好像折錯了你看
你不趁那時候美一戰爭的時候
未明的時候我趕快跟你講要出掉的時候
我看你都會這樣套到這邊
這一堆賞戶套到記憶體怎麼辦
這跟大家講
是不是
相對我是說我寧願買比較低機器的什麼
國具你看今天國具是不是還拉起來
是不是
沒關係拉拉拉
確定的多頭再去買也沒關係
我就覺得要買低的
華星哥
對不對就像3037
星星
今天還在漲啊我說我不管他啦
我把它丟掉1800一檔嘛我找隨便找個啊
1800個人我可以
我們可以取我們可以價嘛對不對
所以你不用想那麼多嘛我們可以交往
所以你不用錢那麼多
你幹嘛一定要選那種比較貴的
不需要
星星最好笑的是什麼
星星最好笑的是我一直常常講
我說之前還有那不知名的媒體
無聊的分析師
攻擊我 攻擊我的星星
投資廟 現在要負責任嗎
這件事要負責任嗎
害死別人了
那時候說我是不是故意害大家背錢的
是害死別人了
那時候星星星120幾塊
抵到七八十元就好像有害大家
結果如果你是我的粉絲
你可能七八十元
你可能在底部你還敢加碼
七八十元你敢加碼
就算你不敢加碼
至少你會抱著
只要你願意相信我
323元看起來真丟臉
怎麼323元就出掉了
笑死人至少我願意抱到323元
我賺161%
你現在就算是600塊的星星
漲到1000塊也賺不到161%
同樣年60年大概差不多賺60幾%而已啊
你這樣找到1000塊賺不到70%
現在星星625了
賺到1000塊也賺不到啊
我323元現在625也沒有我一開始123
賺到323元來的多啊
我少賺一倍又怎麼樣
可是我最多賺161%
我這個股票都是安全下專
安全下專
我要強調的是安全下專
所以你去想看尼亞棧的分析師啦
我都不去私後啊 不去馬後炮啊
機體真的怪怪的
這真的不應該這樣走啊
這樣走不好
創建型這樣子 南亞科最奇怪然後還有2344滑彎店滑彎店看景師他做頭啦你看這個你家是WD你是M頭再看一次喔這是滑板電嗎
看一下喔
你看這美觀手是不是
要創新高
Sandisk已經創新高了
SK海利是有沒有看到
我們在這邊
XK也在這邊
看起來怎麼樣創高
可是也沒有
三星也是一樣
我們在這邊
都怪怪的
你看這邊
有沒有像
我們要在這邊
所以明天的記憶體要談
如果明天的記憶體還沒有談
記憶體應該死定
確定真的是over
二次over
一次over就最好賺之段沒有over了
那時候我定義over也對了
過年前那時候是最好賺的
過年前那時候最好賺的
就像星星你看到今天漲
其實是100多塊到300多塊那時候最好賺
記憶體過年前最好賺
我沒有錯 記憶體我沒有錯
不是跟你開玩笑的
記憶體一堆股票在過年前是最高
後面給你死毛跳
死毛跳那個跳很快
而且不是每一檔都死毛跳
只有少數像威肝這種
最好賺的是這一段你知道
這一段啊
100塊不到
然後早上400塊賺到三倍啊
這邊一下子賺100%好像是厲害
他是死毛跳
逃命波啊
你不要看別人家投顧人在表演啊
那是表演而已啊
很多人講這跟美育戰爭沒關係
現在才是越來越跟美育戰爭沒關係
現在股市還可以這樣講
之前不能這樣講
沒有錯啊 之前不能這樣講啊
之前哪一天不是都沒戰爭影響
所以講當然這些老師我覺得不負責任
只是因為他們就想要每天講比較苦笑
不用解盤啦
算最簡單啦
賞戶比較好騙
當然我還是強調一下
我不會特別針對別人
我到這年紀我也沒有在乎錢
我也不怕被我也不怕告人家
可是我也不想去告人家
因為我覺得
人生很多事要做
太誇張我才去
才回去告
我在告別人之前我都會聲警告一下
現在告別人也蠻麻煩的
因為告他好多件
結果因為現在台灣太多被那種
真正那種詐騙集團影響
書記官或一些朋友在法院上班的
或是律師的或是檢察官的朋友們
都說現在法院被癱瘓
現在你告人家你以前一兩年內
一兩年內基本上就可以結案了
現在要拖到兩三年以上
因為台灣都被案件給癱瘓了
差很多
他們也是蠻辛苦的
這些法律人士也是蠻辛苦的
所以你記得一件事
我的 IG 啦
IG 這個還 OK
我的 Tray 我的臉書不要理他
因為我都檢舉大便集團
結果反而被大便集團給檢舉
基本上我現在有一個臉書的帳號啦
那可是問題是你可以看那個文章
可是你不要跟那裡面的人講話
因為你可能分不清楚是哪個是真的我
哪個假的我
我帳號已經被封鎖好多次了
所以你不要理臉書
不要理trade的我
記得
只可以看那個Line的我
Line多一個A少一個A
或多一個S少一個S都不行
好不好 OK嗎
以Google
以YouTube為主
因為YouTube最認真抓詐騙集團
今天只要一個假的郭忠祐給我上架影片
在YouTube上面
我當天就可以下架他
好 OK嗎
所以以YouTube裡面介紹的這些帳號為主
就這麼簡單
你也不要聽什麼語音的
我告訴你現在很多聲音
真的假的你分不清楚
你懂不懂真的學的很像
我有看過學的很像
我告訴你這帳號是我的
你聽起來很像我的聲音沒錯
看他假的聲音
以YouTube的帳號為主
YouTube介紹的LINE帳號KG帳號為主
這樣怎麼懂
臉書TRAID都不要理他
ok嗎
不知道沒關係啦
以這個0800668085
ok嗎
這個就是這個電話一定是真的
OK OK 好不好
080來來 80幫我 好不好 OK
所以我要告訴你
可是美衣戰爭可能越來越
越影響越來越小了
台灣下面的是
股價進支比跟本益比過高
可是美股在漲嘛
因為AI真的越來越好用
AI越來越好用
我今天看了一個新聞就是說
馬斯克看他特斯拉股價一直在跌
他說FSD14
已經超越一般人的駕駛水準了
我只希望
各個玩友們趕快跟台灣交通部建議一下
我很想買
我打算買特斯拉的車子來
事實上我已經訂了最後一批的X
就是特斯拉X的車子
是OE那個車門
然後OE那個車門
最後一批就是我買的
好
那我希望大家開發FSD
讓我去看一下特斯拉好不好用
好不好
讓我感受到AI的感覺
這樣我就想要環島旅行
你這樣看環島
開個十幾個小時
你在車上你可以休息啊
聊天啊
又不用特地找司機啊
這很棒
跟大家講
來
那還有來我們來看一下
這個
一樣喔
所以我們剛剛講是記憶體OK
不是記憶體
記憶體不OK
然後老AI裡面
管達應該展真的
管達技術線型不錯
OK
我去那時候我在買的OK啊
不能290買
賣就有300億我覺得都還好啊
你不要選錯嘛
你看現在因為
我也想買紅海可是有時候
可憐之恩必有可悲之處
我不是賣紅海可悲啊
可是有時候股價
他漲跌不上去
他漲不上去有理由
啊這隻的房地可以買可以啊
可是我會有時候等不了一年啊
你訂了嗎
如果一年的話
我一年以上的話
那紅海現在馬上必著已經買
如果是要一個月的話
那可能管打會比較好
OK嗎
差別 你看我現在開始在陸陸續講股票了
戰爭開始鈍化了
除非他真的有一個大的一個激烈的一個行情的波動
就是你看起來就是一輩子要封守恨摩之海峽
就是義然要跟你魚屍玩破
看起來沒有啊
義然的議長啊
還說你毀約三項啊
講得很認真啊
結果還不知道去巴基斯坦剛才開會
嘴巴說不要身體很誠實
我只看一個人 我不看一個人嘴巴說
我都看一個人的行為
我看員工也是這樣
我嘴巴說沒有用
我看行為
行為這最準的
這跟大家講
來來來來
來來
2337萬宏
這也是有點開高走低
開高走低
我有時候突然
我有時候不知道為什麼
覺得我有時候停下來
因為我剛才想說
我本來想跟你講我們公司一個八卦
可是不想講
就是當我面說完話
後來其實都被我抓包了
就是八卦實在是有點大又不大
又不管什麼事情
舉這個例又不好
因為我想說不影響工作表現就算了
公司有一些可能誰跟誰的愛情八卦
或住屋此類的
我有時候看一眼就知道了
明明就在一起在一起不是不好啦可是兩個人算了我扯遠了不應該在一起啦好不好或許是啦好啦不重要不重要不重要
我扯遠了我扯遠了
我看我這一段應該到時候又被人家傳出去的
反正沒關係
反共是100多人
有些人可能覺得我在講他
我們我是全台庫 頭庫最大的
扯遠了啦
不錯我今天體力
依依我今天是不是比昨天好很多
對
好非常多
還可以講笑話
我前天根本沒有講笑話
好非常多
我跟你講我還練習那種呼氣的訓練
呼吸訓練
我第一天一顆都不行
現在已經可以好多次了
可以講多次了
肺活量回來
好啦
所以我真的是燃燒生命
跟大家聊聊天
我希望大家看到的是我認真的人生
人生有時候這樣子真的是
有時候走馬燈看你人生的時候
重點是什麼
我希望你看到這只是很認真的
希望大家賺錢
希望大家每天過得開心
開心這之後
開心再健康
開心跟健康到病存
其他就是賺錢的
賺錢怎麼那麼多
賺錢也很重要好不好
因為沒有錢也
沒有錢萬萬不能
這三件事做完以後
人生就滿足了
你懂嗎 就滿足了
所以我們趕快來努力賺錢
真的更難
然後
306金號科
我們看306金號科
這也不對啦
都不對
都不對啦
2345好飯店
這也不對
所以按照我覺得
依依你覺得按照我的復原程度
下禮拜一有沒有辦法直播
你感覺啊
不是
我覺得可以
你覺得可以齁
就起來越順
我今天只有NG一染色而已嘛
我們禮拜二的時候回來的時候
NG大概五六次
你要多小時嗎
你看為了錄影
我都不想講
我帶眼鏡頭
真的是燃燒生命
第一天啦
這樣還好啦
燃燒生命
就為了跟大家
其實這樣不會很嚴重啦
就小手術
只是問題是
這個
就是不能講話
這不能講話
因為講話很喘
你知道嗎
這第一天比較麻煩
所以這邊準備很多東西
好像電風扇吹著我你知道嗎
你看
電風扇
幫我灌氣
我覺得這比較OK
其實大家能看到我的努力啦
可是我說實話啦
如果只能做努力不能讓你賺錢
你也不要參加
只有自信接下來讓你賺
只能說前陣子沒辦法讓你賺到那麼多
少賺一些些啦
可是說少賺
我也不知道欸 我在想一件事
如果那時候我
沒有喊空我做桌
我做粒基店我現在會賺錢嗎
好問題欸
你不要看很多老師在表演啊
我做金豪科我會賺錢嗎
我會買這邊賣這邊
我不會像那些老師
有些老頭部會跟你說謊話欸
會讓你賺錢嗎
我跟你講這一波很多老師收的很好
因為他可能叫你金豪科160買
220你賺很多 升級續約了
你知道嗎
這邊跌下去了
我講是比他投過
下去了
你還是跟著他 因為你覺得
這邊回來成本
他也賺到你的匯費了
什麼都有了
你來跟著他
可是就績效而言是不好的
這金豪科他要上去
如果我们是我刚才讲那些股票怎么办
地基点怎么办
连上去都没有上去啊
上去一点点而已啊
还有什么
还有那个南亚科怎么办
怎么办嘛
那阿科更长啊
13比13还低啊
那阿科都不好
你说别家公司股价位好
我不相信
可能存取的
neverage这块有机会啦
但也不會多好
你說這人都忘紅嗎
這麼巧嗎
所以我要講的是你看上規則好像創新高
可是賞物最熱門的股票
很多沒有漲
所以這邊選股很重要
美一戰爭我得要說了
我當然也希望我們買到3萬點
那大家算更多勝算更高可能高到99
可看起來不如意
那沒關係我們只是少賺一些
除了是期貨會員
期貨會員就講
期貨會員大概100%的會員裡面
大概兩位
差不多這個比例才是期貨會員
比較對不起期貨會員
不然其實就股票而言的話
我們只是少賬而已
所以我就是努力的
趕快讓大家賺錢
我下禮拜原則上就應該會去做多
至少選一些股票
像管達也好
因為台灣股市只要沒有落底
只要沒有確定沒有破底的話
很多股票其實是還金翻的
在閃爍
那火眼睛睛看更多股票
我要強調一件事
很多記憶體
如果那時候我在想
那時候不是每一戰爭
然後台股市又沒有跌下去
我會不會就提早做多
那我買記憶體會不會反而害了大家
是有可能的
很多老師都是看哪一檔的股票展
說他有
投資者你還是要注意這個邏輯好不好
不論怎麼樣我就是敢預告在前面
不論對貨錯我就是敢預告在前面
你去想看你要怎麼分一次好不好
贵卖指数就在创新高了
好奇怪可是很多股票却下去了
就是说选股票很重要
如果你认同哲哲的话
不认识你是因为努力的话
当然我就要接近一件事
不要只要因为我努力
参加我会员
当然很多人有些人是这样子
有些人是这样子
谢谢你们
可是应该是看我努力的帮你们赚钱
能帮你们赚钱才重要
好不好
欢迎来电客群0800668085
或叫LINE私讯我
不论对我有错哲哲
一切一切
預告在前面去想看你要展開分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
我們準備進場用力去做多
我們趕快來找一檔股票來用力的搶進它
讓它展平板
預祝各位賺大錢
謝謝各位
觀眾朋友們注意喔
最近詐騙盛行
我則則只有三個官方帳號
除此以外都不是喔
第一個帳號是LINE的官方帳號
LINE AT小阿索A178
還有Telecon的官方頻道
小阿索A178178
還有Telegan私人帳號
小小小數是S178 178
反正如果是多一個或少一個單字
通通都是假冒的喔
只有這三個帳號
謝謝喔
最大的一個財經頻道
謝謝各位